okay so I'll take over for this uh this
next part of the lab so the next part of
the lab we're going to talk about
clustering and focus on two two main
kinds of clustering that are you know
likely the most popular clustering out
one is Cam's clustering and the other
one which is a a sort of top down
clustering and then Hier ccal clustering
which is a bottom up
clustering or divisive c means versus
agglomerative um
hierarchical okay so um now K means uh
is going to be fit using something again
from psyit learn um it's an unsupervised
method uh so because it's from Psychic
learn we're going to fit it using the
fit method but as we saw for principal
components when we actually fit uh K
means we're going to just we're not
going to have a response it's just going
to be fit on the the the set the set of
features so here we generate some data
we'll plot uh the two CL we we sort of
made two natural classes in the data
we'll see in a minute and then we're
going to fit K means um here with two
clusters so k equal 2 and we have this
argument here n in it which is how many
random starts to try to find to try and
find an optimal clustering and of course
we use the same random state to
reproduce our our results so we can when
we each time we run the code we'll get
the same
answer okay you one key thing after you
have run um K means is you want to see
what points are assigned to what what
cluster and that's the the labels
attribute and uh okay so that's an array
here we can see that uh as we had kind
of constructed our data in two classes
and it sort of perfectly separates them
if we if we look at how this data is
constructed the first 25 are sort of in
one class the next 25 are another and
it's kind of perfectly found that for
us okay so let's make a plot of the K
means uh plotting by label nice choice
of color there Jonathan yes did you
choose it uh well you
know I must say I think I think python
chose that for me I I'll leave it at
that but yes I think it looks better in
the book yes on the on the on the
monitor here the yellow is quite hard to
see but um so we didn't uh so I'll just
go back to the the the plot here so we
made a scatter plot of our data and um
here the color argument that's C we
colored by the label um and so uh this
data was was constructed to be very
separate and and C does a great job here
at at separating them but of course in
practice you know we don't really know
that our data is nicely separated and we
don't really know that two is the right
amount so we could try fitting you know
we might have to try fit K means with
other numbers of clusters so let's just
look at what happens when we fit three
clusters to our um our data set instead
of just the
two okay so this plot is essentially the
same as before except the the estimator
here the Cam's estimator has three
clusters so the colors there are going
to be three colors one of them is still
that yellow that was hard to see but
there's a yellow cluster over here and
then a green and a blue and we can see
here it's it's hard to say that this is
uh this doesn't seem as good as the one
before it seemed to have actually not
even split sometimes you might see K
means would split a big cluster into two
but it's kind of taken a bit off the
edge of each sorry let's it's taken a
bit off the edge of each of these
clusters and if this is a very toy data
set we can actually see it in two
Dimensions it's rather hard to visualize
what's going to happen in higher
Dimensions okay so one of the arguments
we we talked about in the estimator is
this n and it argument and it's um
recall that the the the way the K's
algorithm runs as discussed in the
lectures is that there's an initial
random assignment to clusters and then
the C's algorithm tries to incrementally
improve the within cluster sum of
squares um that is to make it as small
as possible by swapping points between
clusters however every different
initialization could result in a
different uh solution so we encourage um
you to run many and that's what this
init argument an init argument does it
runs 20 and and then takes the one that
has the best uh within cluster sum of
squares so here we'll just compare using
one fit to 20 fit on our data this data
is pretty nicely separated even with
three clusters it makes some difference
using 20 we got uh you know a roughly 5%
Improvement in in within cluster Su
squares
okay so the other clustering type of
clustering we're going to talk about is
hierle clustering and remember um the
main one the main difference between
between K means and Hier clustering is
in high clustering we start with small
clusters and build them up as you know
as we go along the path whereas K means
just directly tries to break into a
fixed number of
clusters so in h clustering one of the
biggest choices you have to make is um
is so the so-called linkage and remember
that's the rule that's used that that
decides how clusters are merged the
three main uh linkages are complete
single and average and you know I would
say rule of thumb complete is kind of
you know often has nicer clusters than
the other two we'll see an example later
about sing Single has this deficit that
the there's often no in the dendrogram
which we'll see in a moment there's not
a nice place to break whereas complete
sometimes has a bit better place okay
well in terms of the code um it is again
a pych learn estimator uh though it's
not well it's not a it's an unsupervised
estimator so again we fit it with just a
set of features
X
okay so in this has fit something that
that we can use to produce a a
dendogram uh and we'll see how to plot
dendogram a little bit
later so we'll also here just for
completeness we'll use the the other
linkages and we'll plot their genograms
as well so the difference between these
three methods is just the linkage and
let's compare the
genogram so to fit hierarchal clustering
uh we need some notion of distance K
means actually needs data points
themselves to to fit but hro clustering
can be fit just using a a a distance
Matrix and doesn't even really have to
be formally a distance matrix it's
something like a distance Matrix and I'm
just we're just showing you here how to
fit such methods uh such clusterings
instead of using fitting on X we're
going to fit on a distance Matrix so
this is a distance Matrix between all
pairs of observations in the in the data
frame yes all pairs all rows in the data
frame allows right often like for
principal components we are looking at
the the the the variance Co variance of
the features that's one of the important
things in principal components here this
is a distance Matrix of of the rows or
the cases in the data set so we had 5050
observations so we'll have a 50x 50
distance
Matrix and uh that's the only
information needed to fit hierarchal
clustering so we can fit it with uh the
distance Matrix so here instead of being
like an uh a matrix that has cases and
features this is just cases by cases so
50 by
50 okay let's plot our first dendogram
so we're going to plot the dendogram for
the complete
linkage um and so one of the things
you'll often want to do is cut a
dendogram that every well let's look at
the picture then I'll go back to what
what one of those arguments so here's a
picture of a
dendogram uh and the points here there
are 50 individual points uh we can see
their labels they're relatively small
here but uh nevertheless these are the
individual labels of the of the
observations and then each height here
corresponds to some value in that D
Matrix where these two clusters uh were
merged and for average so for complete
and single it is always a value in the D
Matrix for average it's going to be some
function of the values in the D Matrix
but roughly speaking this is the
distance at which the Clusters were
merge for all of the
linkages and so here we can see we know
this data has two classes or two natural
classes because we constructed it that
way so if we were to cut this dendogram
here that would break this the the into
two clusters and so any cut to the
dendogram is related to a cluster and
that's what these arguments up here are
related to so there's a um a threshold
we can use to cut the plot of the dender
such that anything below will be broken
into different colors so here I've put
the color a negative Infinity so there
will be no cut and everything above the
threshold is black and that's why we got
this picture we'll see if some Cuts in
just a
minute okay um so if I change the color
threshold here I'm going to color it
change the threshold to
four oh so that effectively has put a
line here and now we can see separate
clusters we can see so cutting here Cuts
these four branches and then there are
different sub trees each sub tree
corresponds to a
cluster so you can um specify a value to
cut uh like when you actually fit the
fit the fit the clusterer you can
specify four or you can also specify a
number of clusters because there's uh I
think there's what n minus one clusters
as you go up the tree and so you can
specify and they sort of they're ordered
by The Heights these things occur at so
if you want to cut with five clusters
there is some value here you can cut and
get five clusters and you can uh use the
the estimator the Cy learn estimator to
get that as
well okay so act the the function that
does this cut is this function called
cut tree here we specified four clusters
and it's actually going to be equivalent
to having cut at four but but I also
could have cut this at 4.1 or 3.9 and I
would get the same number of clusters so
you can there's also an argument here
where you can put a instead of a number
of clusters you could put an actual
distance
number or the height yeah the height at
five